first of all i've been a fan of your
work for a while i'm glad we get to
finally talk
um during the pandemic i ask everyone
the same two first questions
uh and they are uh what tv series would
you love to
guest direct then why
you know the wire is amazing um what
movie or movies do you think you've seen
the most
counting when i was a kid
probably i remember i had a vhs
of uh to remember the
box of uh apocalypse now
that was uh impossible to read anymore
was completely destroyed for the time
i've seen
uh the movie oh because you watched it
so many times
yeah but now it's something i do less
because i was me when i was
14 20 30
i was uh re-watching movies and now it's
something i
never do okay um your dad
uh was a director he did some spaghetti
he did some spaghetti westerns
and i'm curious when you were a kid did
you
grow up on these movie sets and did you
realize
wait a minute i want to direct as well
yeah i remember exactly the moment where
i
understand how is
how will they make this movie because i
was
you know you're a kid you're going to
set and then
a little bit in the editing and then in
the mixing room and then where they
compose the
soundtrack so it's like you
learn different pieces
but you don't understand exactly how it
works the machine
and uh and then a day i was watching a
western that unfortunately i don't
remember the title
but i was there and then i remembered
the
emotion of putting together
all the pieces where is it whoa i
understand that they do
smaller pieces and then they cut all
together they put the music so i
i i said whoa that's
a wonderful job also because
i was a kid and i was a kind of
jealous of these adult
people that they were playing with much
better toys than
me because they were on
real horses not a thick room
a real gun and not just your thumb
and your finger so what's crazy is it's
oh really it's possible to be
a kid for so long the answer is
yes just be a director
that's that's a great story um did your
dad ever share
any advice that you've taken with you
your entire career
absolutely one and
is that never
make a movie just
for this story try
always to figure out if
the movie could eventually
make sense but not just in political way
but
in in the way that has to be relevant
for the society you are living in that
it's like
exactly what i did because it was right
because otherwise it's just a movie
no that makes complete sense um gamora
is now streaming on hbo max here in the
states
and it seems like it's gotten a new life
um
what's it been like for you watching the
show sort of
get more popular now yeah i was
essentially i was uh really
glad because uh it was
sincerely unexpected because i remember
the first time i was in the editing room
with my editor and we watched the
different the pilot that we were cutting
together we said i said
whoa it's cool but i mean it's
too brutal it's too i mean it's in
napoleon and no one
i mean it's like it's gonna be if we are
lucky
a cult show but not
for a wide uh audience
and then what's wrong so to me
was a big big surprise that makes sense
but i was uh
surprised i am a big fan of the sicario
movies
and taylor told me a while ago that he
envisioned it as a trilogy um
have you heard if a third movie is going
to happen
i think they were
keep talking about i
never had anything real uh
specific and precise i know that
the idea was to make a trilogy
i think that probably uh taylor
had had something has something in
his mind probably i don't know if you
put together
a real scripture yeah hopefully it will
uh happen
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today your current movie
um one of the things that i know about
you is you like doing
stunts with the actors and putting them
in these situations
um and i'm just curious can you talk a
little bit about filming that airplane
sequence
because it is uh pretty good thank you
very much sir
i mean it's like i i like
when i this is bad to say
i don't like action for action in movies
in general
i like when the action
is able to tell you something about the
character
that is involved in the action i like
when
more than the action itself you
feel what your character
get or how we change or how
the action affect his soul so
of course you in order to do so you
you need to be and i did it the same for
example in
sodado it's the big shootout
where you have uh that it's almost
done in the in the car
through isabel eyes
and so in order to do so
you have to be really close to the actor
in order to create a sort of
intimate experience
uh but of course the
reverse is that you cannot use double
or uh stuntmen
you need to ask actor and the cast
to play almost everything on their own
and
in the airplane sequence was uh
crazy complex because of course if you
do everything with your cast means
that you need to shoot the movie
almost entirely practically
so with the little help from the visual
effects but trying to do
almost everything for real
because then also uh
your actor in the performance
is gonna be helped by being for real
in an airplane that is rotating
on his axis so full of water
and uh and then of course for sure the
underwater sequence was uh
crazy because it does a lot of different
components and we shot it as a
a tracking shot so you stay
with the my goal during the entire
uh crash and
then we basically we bought
an airplane we cut it in pieces
and we emerged it in a tank
and then with the complex system of
piston and motor we rotate and so was uh
let's say crazy to do because of course
having
your cast doing the same you need to do
a lot of rehearsal
to be absolutely sure that they are safe
because of course it's like this is the
priority
uh and then i think this one was a crazy
sequence and then
underwater and michael was really
brave and uh and smart because he did
everything on his own so he was under
water he was holding the breath
for a minute too but for real i was like
well but then that way was possible for
example
to keep the shot longer
and to cut just when you take a break
a breath so that that way you are like
oh you feel that you are out of breath
too so it was like a combination of
elements that was pretty
crazy to shoot but i i love that
sequence
what is it like having a conversation
with the people who are insuring the
movie
are you like basically do they ever say
to you no
not really but they are i mean for the
burning car
the the producer when i
showed them the car burning they were
like
whoa are you kidding we are never going
to
send uh michael there and this is free i
mean it's
safe and then it did so
but uh you know what at the end
it's like it's just about it changed a
little bit the process they were
scared but not for for the safe
for the safety because this of course
you want to be safe and you're going to
build and to think about everything in
order to
get the result to be absolutely safe
because it's not that you have to
to shoot the scene once you have to
shoot it three four times and then
the day after you keep shooting so you
don't want to have
um near
small injuries on them it's it's
difficult because then you have
it changed a little bit the process of
the
prep because you need to do a lot of
stuff
in advance you need to train them a lot
you need to do several rehearsal
so uh this was the scariest
thing for uh for producer and financiers
but they agreed because it was a
challenge i'm always curious about the
editing process
because that's the final rewrite can you
talk a little bit about what you learned
in the editing room
um you know to make the final cut and
did you have a much longer version
no my you are seeing it's
uh almost a director's cut
just a little bit uh shorter so we
didn't cut
uh really anything it's i don't know we
left uh
three 314 no not a lot
i mean it was uh we were pretty
uh precise and then i feel that i
i love the editing room it's the
i like very much the writing process
and the editing the set it's a mess
because i mean it's like you have
you have just problem to solve and it's
like
somehow it's never exactly
as it was in your mind it's slightly
different
even better most of the time it's always
better
but in the in the the editing room
is the moment where you really
do the movie and i love to do so and i
we did this thing during the pandemic
and so it was crazy because i did it
home
that was kind of cool experience i've
spoken to a lot of directors and they've
told me about the editing experience
during the pandemic and
just how different it is it's cool you
know i mean it's different
but it's cool because it's like it's
more
intimate it was crazy because we i was
here
in a room and then the idol was in
berlin and then
the other people were in l.a
our vfx was in munich so we were spread
out
all around the globe and we were working
like this
sharing uh i mean it was a
was a kind of strange intimate
and we had more time that is good
you the movie was originally being
released by paramount and now it's
coming out on
amazon you can argue that more people
are going to see it
around the world because of the amazon
release um
what are your thoughts on it coming out
on amazon and streaming
i think it's cool especially in this
moment i mean it's like
this is a moment where the film industry
is facing uh i mean it's it's
not a disaster but it's something never
happened
before so uh
i i still prefer watching
movies in the film theater but in this
moment it's like it's uh it's their
only logical choice because uh
uh a lot of people is gonna watch it
and also if i may in this moment
where i mean you are stuck home
we are condensingly we are a little bit
depressed because i mean we cannot do
what we normally do i mean and then we
have a
sort of creepy atmosphere around you
so i think it's kind of a gift to be
able to
show a movie of this scope it's a sort
of
gift to to the audience that is going to
be
home enjoying and sending texting
right after so it's like uh
it's a different um
experience for sure but what can we do i
mean we don't talk about alternatives so
it's like uh
it's good i'm curious what you're
thinking about doing next
what are you currently developing i'm
working on a western
uh and it's the name it's called
as the gun and it's based on the latest
treatment
sergio leone wrote before dying
it's a question with kids kind of cool
and dennis lien wrote
the script that is
i've heard of this and i didn't realize
how did you
acquire this i'm assuming other people
have thought about using his material
uh yeah because um
the leone's daughter and son called me
they asked me to do it and then i said
whoa
of course um do you think it's gonna be
do you think you'll be filming this year
do you think this is definitely yeah
the idea is to start shooting uh this
winter oh got it is it in
are you gonna shoot in america uh
partially
partially in america in us partially in
europe
are you already thinking about casting
or is that still too far away
uh we're thinking about casting i'm i
will never say anything to you
but
[Laughter]
completely my last question about it um
because i like asking about
stuff like this uh can you reveal like
when does it take place
is it something in the 1800s uh what
what
is the era no no no not yet
i understand i won't i won't push you
any further um
my last thing for you um talk a little
bit about uh your relationship with
taylor sheridan because obviously you've
worked with him a number of times and
you got him to contribute working on the
script for this
can you talk about you know getting him
for without remorse and
what's it like to collaborate with him
all right i like him
very very much i mean we have uh
of course he's slightly different but
more or less we have the
the same approach to the storytelling
and i like him because he he pays a lot
of attention
on the psychology of the character
and then he likes the action
but uh it feels uh as
i feel but it's more important to still
follow them the characters
and uh i i love is uh
here for the um for the dialogue
i mean it's like i love how he writes
styles
and then it's like um and of course in
without rewards we since was pretty
challenging the idea itself to
modernize a tom clancy book because i
mean it's
such a big order that was like oh yes
let's do it but we need to be really
respectful
and careful in doing so so i
i need to to have
with me someone i really trust and i
really know that it's a
smart respectful author
yeah he's kind of talented he's okay
right on that note i gotta go wish you
nothing but the best
please stay safe i look forward to this
western
thank you very much sir